wieso
[Musik]
mark zuckerberg ein visionär der mit
technologie die welt beflügelt so
inszeniert er sich auf instagram doch
dieses image hat kratzer bekommen
er ist der chef eines unglaublich
mächtigen unternehmens mit drei
milliarden usern aus einem wert von
einer billion us dollar und auch agiert
eher so als ob er das fahrwerk seines
flugzeuges erst baut wenn es schon in
der luft gezeigt
facebook riskiere die sicherheit seiner
user und gefährdet die demokratie
davon sind die beiden reporterinnen
cäcilia keng und schira frenkel
überzeugt in ihrem buch und ugly truth
eine hässliche wahrheit werfen sie mark
zuckerberg und co geschäftsführerin
sheryl sandberg einen skrupellosen
expansionskurs vor
der buchtitel stammt von einer
führungskraft er spricht von einer
hässlichen wahrheit um die realität bei
facebook zu beschreiben wie die
führungsriege wiederholte ähnliche
entscheidungen trifft und fehler in
myanmar oder anderswo macht die dazu
führen dass menschen getötet werden
sie töten menschen mit diesem satz hat
us-präsident beiden vor kurzem facebooks
umgang mit desinformationen in der
pandemie kritisiert das weiße haus
fordert dass facebook daten zu
falschmeldungen über impfungen
herausgibt doch die führungsebene von
facebook habe zu beginn der pandemie
abgelehnt mehr ressourcen für eine
solche erhebung bereitzustellen
in der vergangenheit schien sich
unternehmenschef zuckerberg nicht für
das verantwortlich zu fühlen was
facebook millionenfach verbreitet er sei
kein schiedsrichter über die wahrheit so
formulierte er es einst facebook hält er
für eine neutrale plattform
den missbrauch bei einem user verortet
aber nie wirklich im unternehmen und
selbst wenn er wenn das unternehmen was
wir jetzt haben auch häufiger wieder
passiert dann doch verantwortung zu gibt
bei gewissen sachen das dann eher gesagt
ja wir haben wir haben die wir haben die
technologie falsch bedient wir haben uns
die falschen fragen gestellt und so
weiter das system an sich ist nie dran
schuld
standort im herzen des silicon valley
hier bekommen tech pioniere ihr
intellektuelles rüstzeug hier lehrt
adrian taub literaturwissenschaft in
seinem buch was das valley denken nennt
nimmt er denke ihnen in den blick der
sich die tech-branche bedient ich glaube
dass ich in den letzten fünfzig sechzig
jahren in nord kalifornien eine art
denke etabliert hat die ganz stark
profit und technologische innovation
über sicherheit und über werte gestellt
hat die sozusagen die kommunikation
und den individualismus
als wert an sich entdeckt hat
das medium ist die botschaft der
kanadische medientheoretiker marshall
mcluhan wurde durch diesen satz in den
1960 er jahren berühmt für ihn formen
medien und nicht inhalte unsere
wahrnehmen
so greift das medium facebook heute tief
in die psyche seiner user ein in dem es
bestimmt wie wir informationen teil
die plattform ist alles inhalte
nebensache erst ein solches denken
ermögliche mark zuckerberg einen
skrupellosen expansionskurs die tatsache
dass möglicherweise ein kommunikations
begriff dahinter steckt der nicht ganz
durchdacht ist und dass ich das das ist
wirklich schwierig ist zu sagen wir
verbringen menschen miteinander in
verbindung und wir stellen aber keine
ethischen maßstäbe bereit wie dort
kommunizieren wäre das ist eine frage
die man sich bei facebook sehr wenig zu
stellen scheinen
welche folgen ein solches denken haben
kann zeigen kennen und frenkel in ihrem
buch
2017 startete das militär in myanmar auf
facebook eine desinformationskampagne
facebooks algorithmus verbreitete hass
gegen die muslimische rohingya
minderheit die gewalt eskalierte
25.000 menschen starben hunderttausende
flohen die zentrale in kalifornien habe
jahrelang warnungen von
menschenrechts-organisationen ignoriert
bis 2018 gab es nur fünf bläser
sprechende mitarbeiter innen für einen
markt von 18 millionen usern das
unternehmen habe ein streichholz in
einen ethnischen konflikt geworfen und
sich dann abgewandt so die autorin
mark zuckerberg setzte auch im
wachstumsmarkt myanmar auf sein
zentrales geschäftsmodell
das ist eine der hässlichen wahrheiten
facebook benötigt unbedingt die
beteiligung seiner user um zu wachsen
wachstum ist das wichtigste für das
unternehmen der newsfeed algorithmus
zielt darauf ab user zu binden spült
aufsehenerregendes nach oben eher
priorisiert inhalte die emotionen
erzeugen ist egal ob wut traurigkeit
light oder empörung oftmals dinge die
einen in die irre führen bruder des
informieren
die algorithmische verstärkung von
emotionen die zentrale dna von facebook
für doch steckt hinter diesem
geschäftsmodell ein zutiefst
pessimistisches menschenbild
so findet das denken des französischen
kultur anthropologen und stanford
professor rené girard großen anklang bei
gründern und investoren im silicon
valley
laut ihrer begehren menschen immer das
was andere auch wollen mim ethisches
begehren so nennt er das und so
funktioniere auch facebook das begehren
wird durch den ständigen vergleich mit
anderen und die jagd nach likes geschürt
konflikte und gewalt sind laut ihrer
folge dieser dynamik und doch wird uns
dieses geschäftsmodell als geniale idee
verkauft die die welt näher
zusammenbringt
[Musik]
am 6 januar entlud sich der hass den
facebook gruppen über monate hinweg den
ton angegeben hatte
vor der attacke auf das kapitol empfahl
facebooks algorithmus trump followern
hunderttausendfach gruppen in denen sich
gewaltbereite demonstranten organisieren
jobs selbst befeuerte den mythos der
gestohlenen wahl
zu seinen 28 millionen verloren hatte
ihn zuckerberg noch im herbst 2009 10
gratuliert erst nach dem sturm aufs
kapital es in facebook sperren die
autorinnen kommen zu einem erstaunlichen
ergebnis
[Musik]
facebook wusste bereits vor dem 6 im
januar was sie planten sie waren
alarmiert bemerkten dass personen davon
sprachen waffen mitzubringen fotos
posten und in gruppen geschrieben ich
bringe diese sturmgewehr mit nach
washington
trump solle sich für seine worte
verantwortlich fühlen die menschen die
das gesetz brauchen für ihre taten sowie
sascha berg jegliche verantwortung von
sich
einige leute behaupten dass soziale
netzwerke polarisieren unseren
forschungen zufolge ist das alles andere
als klar
immer wieder betont er dass er an einer
gemeinschaft für alle arbeiter genau
darin liegt das dilemma von facebook die
wirklichkeit eines algorithmus der hass
und gewalt befördert und der anspruch
die welt zu einem besseren ort zu machen
es ist glaube ich unglaublich wichtig
für diese unternehmen wären sie ihm
diese enorme macht anhäufen muss sagen
vor dieser macht auch zu einem gewissen
grad die augen verschließen zu können
und das ist wichtig für die für die
unternehmenschefs das ist wichtig für
diesen expansionskurs es ist einfach
einfach eine art und der man sich selber
belegen kann und sondern kognitive
dissonanz abbauen kann
der unternehmer als held der sich von
niemandem beirren lässt diese
weitverbreitete denkart in der
technologiebranche geht auf die
schriftstellerin ayn rand zurück
säulenheilige des rallys verfechterin
eines ungezügelten kapitalismus
in ihren romanen aus den 1950 er jahren
stemmen sich unternehmer übermächtigen
autoritäten entgegen um ihre visionen zu
verwirklichen
jenny kult und überbordender
individualismus als leitbild diese
gedanken passend zum unternehmergeist im
silicon valley
und stellt ein genie begriff parat der
sozusagen den chef einer firma zu einem
künstler um stilisiert und jeden der ihn
kritisiert als ein kunstgriff der das
kunstwerk nicht versteht das heißt
regulatoren gewerkschaften die presse
sie sind eigentlich nur da das sind die
linke tana die gute wahl am strand
festzurren wollen ich war und das ist
dass ich das das dass so etwas eine mark
zuckerberg imponiert ist ja klar dass
silicon valley hat den anspruch
unverzichtbar zu sein erfolgreich
exportiert eine welt ohne google amazon
oder eben facebook scheint heute kaum
mehr denkbar
frenkel und kay schreiben dass facebook
heute zu groß sei und zerschlagen zu
werden erst jüngst wurde eine
kartellklage gegen das unternehmen in
den usa abgewiesen die rhetorik der
eigenen unersetzlich kite seit zentral
um politisch nicht reguliert zu werden
so darf
es wird immer so getan als führe an
diesem unternehmen kein weg vorbei die
unabwendbarkeit einer technologischen
innovation mit gleichgesetzt mit der
marktdominanz eines einzelunternehmen
ist und ich glaube dass viele dieser
denke genau das ermöglichen und das fiel
dieser denke gerade deswegen bei den
cios ist das beliebte
bei facebook stehe einem wandel heute
vor allem mark zuckerberg im weg
schreiben die autoren
stimmen die eine abkehr von dessen
expansionskurs fordern würden ignoriert
fünf jahre recherche rund 400 interviews
die meisten davon mit mitarbeiter innen
das buch legt den seelenzustand des
unternehmens offen
es fühlte sich fast so an als ob wir in
einer therapiesitzung mit jemandem
sitzen der sich jahre der frustration
und angst von der seele reden will und
eigentlich sind das menschen die sich
sehr um facebook sorgen und wollen dass
facebook ist besser macht
sascha berg arbeitet derweil an seiner
nächsten vision dem sogenannten meta
war's eine art digitale parallelwelt
eine plattform auf der user tag und
nacht verbringen es ist der ultimative
traum der werbeindustrie
[Musik]